well i'm here at the gist buffets
classic center of st. Louis while the
second round just finished of the st.
Louis autumn invitational and i'm joined
here with Josh cola
just played a fantastic game here
against Doug Eckert so he's going to
lead us through the game so thanks for
coming josh and let's go ahead and look
at the board at this point my point and
I we finished the opening stage and I
will consider this position the critical
point the critical moment of the game my
opponent had an option to consolidate
and exchange from pieces by playing the
move 95 with this move he would exchange
the light squared bishops and places
night on a good outpost square but
instead he played the move Brooks c5 now
my opponent after the game told me he
thought my day was to play Knight c4 and
the move the idea behind night c4 is to
block White's see file and limit white
squares for his rook but instead I
played the move Bishop 25 and this move
there's two things it texts upon an a2
and it also protects the beep on because
both my queen and my rope is also
defending
b5 now this makes white paper day one to
protect that a point and now I play the
move 97 and this kicks weights workout
and here i would say that like is
slightly better because i got to
maneuver my pieces to better squares and
white wasted at least a tempo playing
the room playing the work to c5 thanks
Josh for walking us through some of that
game it's always good you know to get a
big win in to turn them in like this and
I guess going forward what do you think
your chances are of getting uh and I am
Norma this tournament oh right now have
I even score of 12 I'm not really
certain of how many points I need to get
but I try not to think about it just
play one game at a time and hope for the
best okay yeah and I believe you our
magic number is six and a half at a nine
so obviously that's not very difficult
to achieve but hopefully you're able to
do it right here in st. Louis and as you
want to see us some more action here
from the 2016 st. Louis on occasional
make sure you go to us chess champs the
link is in the description below and
we'll see you tomorrow for another recap
of all the exciting action here in st.
Louis
you